[Applaudissements]
mais non c'est moi je suis ventriloque
alyzia série b que c'est bien et c'est
siri nani sur la table mais je suis fou
très cher alors attention
rolala là c'est une chaîne tout à fait
extraordinaire que j'ai dans ma vie de
trois mois seulement qui vient de
roumanie mon pays d'origine pour ça que
c'est très émouvant j'ai et puis voilà
je suis maintenant foot ce chien je dors
dans le panier je mange des croquettes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il regarde bien son regard c'est pas un
chien non c'est quoi ça c'est qui c'est
un être humain
elle sait qu'elle a un bon profil
jane russell michel je croyais qu'ils
aiment bien tu as regardé un c'est pas
un chien c'est ta femme
[Applaudissements]